As you're becoming a more discerning programmer, at least a more tasteful one,
there's something about this that should still really bother you, in addition to
the fact that Dave is not getting eaten any more. We've got a big chunk of
duplicated code here. Well, it's only one line, but it could be a lot more,
depending on what you have to do to actually eat someone. If the victim is not
named Dave, both the Discerning Bear and the regular bear and the regular
Grizzly Bear do the same thing. We had to cut and paste that code to get that
behavior here. What we'd like is a way to be able to access the original eat
method of bear from inside the method we're writing to override that method. We
could change the name here, but that wouldn't solve our problem because then
inside chase which is defined inside grizzly bear, we would get the wrong
method. So we can't change the name of this method. It still needs to be called
eat, but we want a way of accessing the eat method of bear. To do this, we need
a special operator, which is the super operator. What super does is it takes A
class and an object, and it returns a special proxy. This is sort of like an
object, except it ignores the new definitions provided by class. What this means
is we can replace the code here with a call to super, passing in discerning bear
and self, and that will mean We're ignoring the overridden eat method. So now
when we get the eat method, we're going to get the eat method from the
GrizzlyBear class, which turns out, is the eat method it inherited from the Bear
class. And the one requirement is that the object that's passed in must be an
instance of the class.